my man loved my muffins let me sniff
your porthole pineapples raining from
snake heaven oh god mark it out of me no
there's this guy sitting at a bar he's
very old married terrible he's just
sitting there hating life and hating
everyone then all the sudden Cthulhu
pops through the doors tentacles
everywhere it's like a bad Japanese
hentai let me sniff your butt hole
this is even today in this action it's
more like a soft Irish Scottish accent
Mitch was a little bit of Canadian but I
don't know would I know I need to fill
my man with love by kissing men among
the back of it the nape of his neck were
you about to turn around and criticize
oh wait no one appreciates how difficult
this is
well that's not normal what you need to
stop this developer goddamn you can't
play random game over tricks when your
save system is so scarce what the [ __ ]
you saw something I saw something but
because I'm not a child at heart I'm
actually a bitter old man who hates box
here you my bro are you my bro bro I'm a
drunk man I don't even push a button to
enjoy backing of the spaghetti kid yes
lost control of my character cuz I was
come back and swing fast enough if you
want I'll hit it first
I'm just thanks for watching all of the
videos in this compilation are available
in the description so check them out and
if you'd like to see more in the future
please leave a like to let me know if
you enjoyed this video and you'd like to
see more on a daily basis please
subscribe today or if you're already
subscribed share this video with a
friend thanks again for watching and
I'll see you in the next video bye bye